stéphanie grammond alec castonguay
christian dufour bonsoir bonsoir en soit
notre sa bouche sur la scène politique
québécoise ce qu'ils à
ses résultats s'arrête une campagne
ennuyeuse pas du tout je n'ai pas
commencé que déjà ça bouillonne il ya
des vieilles des vieux débat qui
ressurgissent alors madame st-hilaire
qu'on a vu hier qui a annoncé donc son
arrivée dans sherbrooke qui voit est une
circonscription à surveiller contre
québec solidaire
je vous fais entendre madame st-hilaire
qui
part du troisième liens parce qu'elle
était plutôt content quand elle était
chroniqueuse
et là vous allez voir aller plutôt pour
et monsieur legault qui parle de ces
souverainistes
qui vont arriver monsieur drainville
demain on écoute ce qu'on revient
à l'époque quand je m'exprimais
notamment sur le troisième ligne faut se
rappeler là c'était loin d'être le
projet qu'on a aujourd'hui
et donc autant le projet a évolué je
voudrais que ma position a évolué pour
plusieurs raisons notamment parce qu'il
ya une offre de transport en commun qui
est très intéressante et que c'est
devenu un réseau structurant pour
l'ensemble de la région et ça que je
trouve que c'est très intéressant pour
les gens de québec mais aussi pour les
gens de lévis alors je vis très très
très bien avec le troisième
non je pense pas dire que je vais
prétendre d avoir fait changer d'idée ce
qui est important par contre c'est que
comme le disait françois
tantôt pendant 40 ans on était divisée
entre souverainistes puis fédéraliste
nous ce qu'on veut c'est faire avancer
la nation québécoise à l'intérieur du
canada donc on y croit aller chercher
plus de poids pour défendre notre langue
nos valeurs notre culture on y croit
puis s'est appuyé par beaucoup de
québécois donc je pense les québécois
sont rendus là et on est oui on est une
coalition en même temps qu'une coalition
nationaliste
coalition nationale est donc j'en en
parlait la semaine dernière la grand
tante qu'il veut élargir encore plus
stéphanie grammond donc coup sur coup
madame st-hilaire monsieur drainville
sur legault dit ça ça illustre un état
de fait
oui c'est certain ben moi ce qui me
frappe d'abord les premières explique
vous avez fait jouer caroline st-hilaire
c'est intéressant de voir comment les
les discours changent quand on quand on
adhère à la caq ça me fait beaucoup
penser à quand charlie de doris mans se
présentait aussi pour marie victorin
elle qui avait été très critique envers
le gouvernement la propos du racisme
systémique le c'est drôle quand elle
s'est présentée tout à coup sa position
avait changé aussi un peu comme celle de
madame st-hilaire sur sur le troisième
lien donc oui car
on ad'un aussi opposition maintenant sur
la question de la souveraineté
c'est sûr que madame st-hilaire qui est
un ancien du bloc monsieur drainville
évidemment qui est un peu le père de la
charte des valeurs ça fait deux ajouts
là qui vont plutôt dans le sens la
souveraineté est ce que ça va peut-être
laissé certains électeurs plus 8 yens
face à la cac avec ce portrait l'heure
ça reste à voir mais c'est sûr que ça
change en même temps est-ce que parce
que la caq voir est ce que monsieur le
goût est vraiment l'intention de cacher
de faire la souveraineté je penserais
pas honnêtement c'est un projet qui que
pas de chance de se concrétiser c'est la
dernière des priorités des jeunes en ce
moment donc je crois pas que ce soit une
crainte justifiée donc comme disait
monsieur bouchard dans une entrevue qui
a fait jaser qui m'a donné vendredi sur
le go at-il dit réaliste lily la carte
actuelle puis il ne voit pas arriver
absolument pas de référendum ou de débat
là-dessus allait quand même c'est un
puissant message qu'il envoie là
dans un souci d équilibre pour garder sa
coalition
intacte faudrait peut-être qu'annonce
une fois de temps en temps une
candidature fédéraliste ça fait
peut-être plus tard peut-être question
y'a lebel et pierre fait guémené que
service saas était bon et seul parce que
ce jeu d'équilibré aussi souvenez vous
quand la cac qui ont été lancés un
moment donné on allait chercher des
députés comme benoit charette il ya eu
françois rebello le saut à la cac ça a
été comme un peu la goutte qui avait
fait déborder le vase là parce qu'il
fera son vélo avec sa conférence de
presse je suis encore souverainiste je
pense que ce projet là encore de
l'avenir puis françois legault et à côté
en zambie pour notre priorité pour les
gens s'étaient demandés quand on suit un
ramassis toutes sortes de monde deux
parties losc a encore une cohérence
idéologique autour de sopi savez savez
vraiment fait mal à la cac à ses débuts
ses succès les plus enracinées la caq
qu'elle était à ce moment là les gens
moins de questions et on croirait le
gouverner n'empêche que ce petit
questionnement la survie ou est-ce qu'on
s'envoie à long terme votre surgissent
on n'est pas capable d'avoir aussi l'
équilibre avec d'autres candidatures
donc je pense pas le kiosque danger en
la demeure actuellement mais faudra
qu'il y pense éventuellement françois
legault s'il veut s'assurer que le mot
coalition est encore tout son sens à
l'intérieur de son parti ceci dit ça
reste des bonnes des bonnes candidatures
car l'institut la bernard drainville
sont capables de bien s'exprimer ils
sont des bons communicateurs ont atteint
une heure de communication les deux sont
ministrable tout à fait alors si on veut
élargir la capacité de la caq a su
renouveler à voir de nouveaux visages à
présenter parce que des ministres qui
sous-performent dans ce gouvernement le
c'est normal comme dans tous les
gouvernements très quatre ans mais ça
prend des figures pour les remplacer on
vient d'en trouver de grands savants est
intéressant de voir la suite christian
bassez dans l'esprit de la caq que tu
nies coalition pu monsieur legault était
lui-même soigneuse que je pense pulsé
c'est important que sol
la différence fédéralistes et
souverainistes et elle souffre et nice
ça veut pas dire ce que ça dès jeudi ils
ont choisi le pouvoir c'est toi qui les
intéressent et le pq représente plus le
poids il faut les juger en fait sur leur
candidature mais quel point c'est
intéressant pour le cdh change courants
moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ceux
qui prennent le risque de la politique
et c'est cruel mais moi je pas convaincu
à ce point là entre autres balades rêvée
pour être très franc parce que bernard
drainville il est très très connu ça
fait vieux stock pas mal être il a déjà
été journaliste la politique ouais non
mais on dit ce qu'on pense ma première
réaction je me suis dit je me suis dit
bon il est journalier s'est fait de la
politique favorable mais ça pas été
transcendant ça a été pas juste un
journal c'est un imam un animateur de
radio tous les jours à montréal de 98
donc est extrêmement connue extrêmement
présents donc c'est pas nouveau soulet
et je pas sûr qu'on a un nationalisme
québécois ferme
mais on veut le juge jean-paul jugé
autrement dit que l'important ce n'est
pas de savoir
est-ce qu'ils vont être performant c'est
ce que je vous regarde mais je reviens
sur ce que vous avez dit à christian
puis je veux je refais un tour de table
là dessus vous dit
c'est pas très important
on n'est plus là à savoir êtes-vous
souveraineté 7 vous comme demain il se
pose la question monsieur de rêver je
veux dire je suis souverainiste surmas
d'un rêve comme monsieur bouchard
distincts rêve qui est là mais je crois
que c'est absolument
irréaliste de penser qu'on peut proposer
aux québécois une démarche incarner
actuellement vers la souveraineté les
deux peuvent aller perdre
avec des collègues fédéral et ceux
concédés mais si la démarche des polos
ça change rien à court terme alex non
oui en effet puis je pense pas que je
suis d'accord avec stéphanie je pense
pas que personne ne s'attend à ce que
françois legault nous faire son
référendum surprise demain matin là
c'est pas dans ses cartons sa coalition
éclaterait mais
on peut quand même se poser des
questions sera plus long terme qu'est ce
qu'on va avoir comme discussions avec
ottawa dans la fédération est ce qu'on
va prendre donc des ministres qui
systématiquement sur pause ou veulent et
en porte à faux avec super tawab f1 ou
est ce qu'on veut en avoir comme sonia
lebel qui travaillent en coulisse qui
réussissent à faire atterrir les choses
et qui ont des solutions à proposer les
deux approches sont assez différentes
entre la confrontation il trouver des
solutions dans le ton dans la manière de
s'y prendre le type de discours qu'on
fait et ça ça va être intéressant de
voir dans la coalition a mené québec est
ce que le ton plus batailleur d'un
bernard drainville qui naturellement
plus batailleur mais françois legault
l'est naturellement plus que bien fait
ce but que sonia lebel christian dubé
qui travaille à trouver des solutions
avec le fédéral parce qu'ils ont tous
les sens effectivement le bout de
s'opposer à ce gouvernement là et ça ça
peut être intéressant sur la fibre
identitaire pour reprendre un mot à la
mode de la caq d'aller mesurer comment
on définit les défilés problème devant
nous soit de façon de soi comprend la
confrontation comme étant le mode où il
peut avoir des
ententes
c'est que des gens en fait qu'ils sont
mis à rêver de la souveraineté à nouveau
dans le contexte de la contestation par
le fédéral de la loi
de la loi sur le français non parce que
c'est comme s'ils sont incapables
d'imaginer québec autre que s'ouvrait le
québec va peut-être être sourd un moment
donné moi je pourrais bien d'arriver
mais il me semble que ça va revenir à un
moment où on s'y attendre pop et des
supputations qu'on fait aujourd'hui moi
je trouve ça un peu d'eux sans intérêt
parce que personne n'en sait unir
définitive ce qu'on sait c'est que des
souverainistes dans laquelle et féret si
c'est la france de françois legault
parce que l'équipe du coach sont
vraiment pas lol le québécois sont pas
très vite
il ya des choses qu'on peut qu'on peut
plus difficilement dire quand on a été
chef du parti québécois
la soeur devenir évêques étaient très
choqués par les propos que monsieur
bouchard tenus sur cette antenne et
d'autres mets essentiellement dans cette
longue entrevue où il a été très dur
envers le parti québécois il le dit si
ce vécu la marche pas y en aura un autre
c'est pas le véhicule l'important c'est
l'idée que l'idée reste vivante il a dit
quand même pour être honnête dans
l'entrevue j'ai un grand respect at il
dit pour les gens qui militent dans ce
parti là mais de proposer au référendum
ce n'est pas réaliste et monsieur
lévesque avait cette qualité là d'être
réaliste ce que n'a pas le chef actuel
bref là la soeur de rené lévesque 93 ans
en furie on va voir un extrait sort et
l'envoi de lettres aux journaux
aujourd'hui en dix ans pendant monsieur
bouchard que vous décrivez le parti
québécois comme un véhicule usées qui ne
méritent pas très bien aller dit que
c'est pas fort que ça clique pas que les
gens ne veulent plus et qu'on en choisir
un autre on vous entend revanche vous
attrister du sort réservé aux
aujourd'hui au parti libéral vols
allaient se leva 93 comme un
tour de table stephanie
monsieur bouchard a dit ce qu'il pensait
mais pour le pq ça ajoute au chemin de
croix la cua oui c'est sûr que le chemin
de croix là il est pénible en ce moment
pour le pq qui va peut-être se retrouver
il a de suite du prochain scrutin avec
un seul député à subir ubéda dans la
matapédia
je sais ce que ça va donner comme
résultat mais pour l'instant ce que les
sondages disent c'est vraiment pas leurs
yeux et puis et bon monsieur bouchard je
pense qu'il a été il était réaliste est
ce que bon c'était le bon moment là
quand on célèbre la mémoire devenus les
vaincre la de dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont
madame lévesque a trouvé ça difficile à
entendre mais en même temps on ne peut
pas cacher la vérité non plus eh ben je
pense qu'effectivement parce que
souligner aussi de du bain
éventuellement ça m'apprendra une
opposition là à québec parce que ce
qu'on voit en ce moment qui se dessine
ses claques accord probablement
tellement de députés peut-être 80 % des
députés malgré le fait qu'ils pourraient
avoir 5 ans 40 % des intentions de vote
et qui voit qu'ils vont lui nir fait
aussi le parti libéral est plus que
l'ombre de lui même si une partie
québécois est rayé de la carte c'est
quand même important dans une démocratie
d'avoir une opposition forte à l'heure
actuelle ce qu'on voit c'est que
effectivement une option suffisamment
est solide pour tenir fin un parti au
gouvernement et on voit pas trop et ça
va venir nous parce que même si par vent
de sympathie pour monsieur legault
monsieur bouchard dit libéraux il faut
qu'ils se relèvent parce que ça c'est
malsain en fait en deux mots avec lui
christian
d'abord récuser un bouchon n'a pas été
tendre envers le parti québécois qui lui
même de quoi était temps de
l'histoire faut rappeler qu'un lucien
bouchard pendant de nombreux congrès
lorsque sa photo apparaît c'est les
militants une lucie bouchard c'est le
seul chiffre du parti québécois qui
avait secrètement le qui lui était
réservé je me souviens lors de la course
à la direction qui va d'ailleurs il eut
pauline marois si ce qui s'était passé
donc il ya quand même toujours une
petite tension ou là entre le pic 8e
bouchard qui est était bien présent mais
en même temps stéphanie raison c'est
très réaliste de le dire et même s'il
n'est pas peut-être un naturel au parti
québécois lucien bouchard 1 qu'il
l'était jacques parizeau avant de
décéder avait dit que le parti québécois
est un champ de ruines on accusera
jamais jacques parizeau de pau être fier
partisan du pq lui qui a été là depuis
ses débuts alors il ya là dedans le
constat qui a certainement matière à
mettre en colère à l'issue des voeux ou
alors plein de militants qui qui sont là
depuis très longtemps mais la réalité à
elle ressemble quand même un super jeu
juste termine en disant lucien bouchard
il est porte parole et président
d'honneur du centième anniversaire de
rené lévesque et non pas du parti
québécois c'est rené lévesque qui la fit
d'eux que lucien bouchard au nord que
déjà été lui-même au parti libéral du
québec nationalisation de l'électricité
donc c'est pas eu ces mouchards de faire
l'apologie du pq c'est pour ça qu'il
doit faire comme pour toi et je vais
partir peut-être qu'ils avaient un petit
mélange des genres notre scout de madame
oui le pq qui n'a pas été tant de crohn
lévesque non plus assuré mais bon
français
christian mémé ben moi je comprends très
bien madame industrie 20 kg totalement
raison et j'espère avoir une telle
vivacité d'esprit à 93 ans est
incroyable son texte parce que c'était
très déplacé en faites pas ce que dit
monsieur bouchard il a oublié qui il
était c'est l'ancien chef du parti
québécois et c'est un ancien premier
ministre péquiste une campagne
électorale qui s'en vient où le pq en
fait juste à pau on peut penser tout ça
on peut penser que le pq est fini mais
lucien bouchard pas lui à dire ça il
dépressif fondamentalement le parti qui
le dirigeait juste avant un combat
électoral je tombe de ma chaise quand
j'écoute après midi parce que ccssl
sacré mon attention là dessus qu'ils
chantent les louanges du parti libéral
heureusement donc l'idée c'est de savoir
s'ils avaient raison pas c'est un
discussions de bon niveau entre vous et
lui mais je trouve que c'était pas
l'ancien chef du parti québécois de
tirer à boulets rouges sur le parti
québécois avant une campagne électorale
et madame lévesque je dis pas ça juste
papa par gentillesse pour quelques
dangers je trouve ça très forts sont le
son texte quand elles rappellent c'est
bien beau mais le bloc québécois ont le
tout sans terry québécois tout ce qu'on
armé il y aurait suscité le parti
conservateur à ottawa lorsqu'il se
retrouve avec deux députés puis jean
charest je suis en train de dire que le
pq vont pas refermées performing
magiquement mais c'est pas encore fait
non mais en fait la mère elle dans
chapeau vous vous dites s'était déplacé
de le dire parce que qu'il le pense on
peut pas lui reprocher de faire une
année de langon de ce qu'il réalise est
ce qu'il est oui mais de dire que deux
promettent un référendum c'est réaliste
et que les
jeux pas d'accord du tout avec son
contrat parce que tout le monde sait que
le parti québécois n'a pas une chance de
prendre de poids donc de promettre un
référendum il faut y voir un sens
programmatique c'est simplement de
rappeler que ni les souverainistes
contrairement à toutes les autres qui se
disent très lisse qui sont aussi déçus
mais pas comme c'est exactement alors je
serai monde se baignent que le pq
renvoie pas le poids donc en tout
respect pour monsieur lucien bouchard
qui est un choix historique moi je
trouve que c'était déplacé et que la
sarre de rené l'a4 13 ans quand même en
vous et moi on eût dit 40 93 99 dollars
grandiose
l'aja rien en mettant bien mais c'est
énorme on y met spontanément quand j'ai
vu le feu dans la vieille madame qu'est
ce que j'ai vu ça j'ai fait savoir tout
de suite notre pierre à cette crise
parce que quelque chose là que vous avez
manqué ça me fait de la peine
intelligente grâce à lui le jeu mais il
était commentateur politique l'ancien
chef non non je comprends mais j'ai posé
des questions purement d apporter les
gens répondent bien heures après tant
d'années monsieur parizeau alec l'adil
au fait ils ont tous fait lisez fait ça
tous les jours ou aux mordus le lieu une
élection dans trois mois environ
comme il reste 1
alalalala on va parler regardons vite le
tableau le pirée patton commenter mais
pour qu'on va parler demain
les cartes de membres vendus pour la
direction du parti conservateur monsieur
poilievre je vais prendre une phrase de
jean françois lisée le parti
conservateur a envie d'avoir sa période
poilievre avec un cinquième est divisée
sur pkp
encore possible qu'ils réussissent à
aller faire voter à mobiliser ses
membres pendant les trois prochains mois
ça va être de très longs mois où on va
c'est depuis chiper des membres qu'il a
récoltés avec l arrêt série culte et
donc ça va être à sens finit quand même
oui on va en parler très intéressant est
ce que monsieur charest peut si vous
alliez avoir pas 50 leçons au début les
deuxièmes choix tout ça merci merci au
revoir merci à la merci